[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم عن محور قناه
السويس تدور حلقتنا اليوم محور قناه
السويس مشروع دولي بالغ الاهميه ليس لمصر
وليس لدول المنطقه ولكن للعالم كله بنستي
اليوم للحديث عن هذا المشروع المهندس وائل
الدور
خبير الملاحه البحريه وعضو مجلس اداره
قناه السويس السابق مساء الخير باشمهندس
مساء النور س ربنا يخلي حضرتك ممكن تدينا
يا باشمهندس فكره بسيطه الاول كده قبل ما
نتكلم عن المحور والتحديات اللي بتواجهه
ممكن حضرتك تقول لنا ببساطه ما هو محور
قناه السويس في سنه 83
1983 اليابان
قالت
لمصر ان هونج كونج هتروح للسياده الصينيه
سنه 90 واحنا شايفين ان السويس ممكن تكون
بديل لهونج
كونج و سنه
84 ادتنا منحه
وخططت شمال غرب خليج
السويس على
مساحه 5 2500 ك متر
مربع عباره عن مستطيل 60 في 76 ك م الساحل
الشرقي والغربي الكنات السويس ايه الانشطه
المختلفه ايه المواني الجديده ايه المصانع
ايه مراكز اللوجستيات ايه كل حاجه عملتها
تخطيط
ممتاز وانتهى هذا التخطيط سنه 86
1986 في هذا التاريخ ما كانش في لا جبل
علي ولا حاجه خالص في دبي في
دبي
نتيجه تسارعات بين رجال اعمال
مصريين اليابان حست ان مافيش شفافيه في
الموضوع فانسحبت من
المشروع وقف هذا المشروع بعد
كده في سنه
1997 طب استاذنك قبل ما تستانف ما حدث في
1997 اوضح حاجه واسال حضرتك عن حاجه طبعا
انا اقدر استنتج ببساطه يعني والباشمهندس
ممكن يصححلي انه اليابان اذا انتقلت هونج
كونج هذا الميناء والمركز التجاري الضخم
من السيطره البريطانيه حيث كانت خاضعه
للسيطره البريطانيه لاكثر من 100 عام
سابقه وانتقلت هونج كونج الى الصين الصين
علاقتها متوتره باليابان فاليابان ارادت
ان هي تلاقي مركز تجاري بديل عن هونج كونج
مظبوط يا
باشمهندس واستانست او وجدت ضلت في محور
قناه السويس وبالتالي دعمت الحكومه
المصريه بالتمويل
والتخطيط ده اولا بس هل ممكن يعني ا ب
ممكن نقول للناس هو ايه الوظيفه اللي كانت
بتعملها هونج كونج في التجاره الدوليه
باختصار وكان يمكن ان تنتقل لمحور قناه
السويس ايه اي هونج كونج بتقدم خدمات
للتجاره الدوليه تموينات سفن تسجيل
سفن اصلاح سفن كل ما يتعلق بخدمات للسفن
بديها وكذلك للتجاره كمنط تجاره حره
استراد وتصدير وتصنيع
وكده بصفه
عاما اي بلد بتقع على المسارات البحريه
العالميه تستطيع ان تكسب ملايين وتنمي
نفسها عن طريق الخدمات والمشاركه في
التجاره فنجد مثلا مثال بلده صغيره جدا زي
سنغافور مساحتها
كلها يعني
724 ر مربع اكتر شويه 7244 تقريبا
حاجه عدد الناس اللي فيها خم ونص مليون
نسمه هذه
البلد لما استقلت في سنه 65 كان
حالها
70% من الناس تحت خط الفقر
ا نسبه البطاله تفوق ال 14% بيشتغلوا في
حاجات بسيطه س سمك خدمه القاعده البحريه
اللي كانت في القاده البريطانيه
البريطانيه فاذا كانت حاجه بسيطه جدا
النهارده لو بصينا لسنغافوره هنجد ان
الناتج القومي
بتاعها
466 مليار دولار يعني تقريبا قد مصر مصر
477 دخل
الفرض من اعلى
الدخول تقريبا
1500 دولار
للفرد نسبه اللي بيستخدموا الانترنت
96% من الشعب هناك نسبه البطاله لا تتجاوز
1.2
من اغنى دول العالم يعني حجم
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه النت الداخل ناقص
الخارج تلاقيه بيجي لها استثمارات
32 مليار دولار سنوي يعني في سنه 2 النت
بلانس 32 مليار تجدي ان الانشطه البحريه
بتساهم ب 7% من الناتج القومي
لسنغافوره تجد مثلا كميه سنغافوره اكبر
مركز
لتمويج يعني السنه اللي فاتت
47.9 مليون طن وقود موتهم لسفن جه بس 37
ال سفينه
و660 جايين ياخدوا وقود من
سنغافور شوف السفن الل جوم للاصلاح
1426 سفينه جايين للاصلاح غير طبعا اللي
بيتدبح
والحاجات الثانيه فيوريك اهميه لما تكون
انت على ممر تغاري دولي
زي كل ما نعرف ان مضيق ملقه ده 20% من
التجاره العالميه بتعبر انا عندي قناه
السويس النهارده
12% من التجاره العالميه بتعبر قناه
السويس مش بس كده ده هي بتربط ثلاث قرارات
اسيا مع اوروبا ومع امريكا وكذلك مع
افريقيا اذا انت في موقع مهم جدا جدا
على خطوط التجاره العالميه استطيع ان انا
احول بلدي من الحاله اللي احنا فيها دي
لحاله تانيه خالص طب استاذن حضرتك برض
اذكر يعني من قد لا يعرف من متابعينا هو
طبعا الباشمهندس لما بتكلم على سنغافوره
واذكركم ان هي واقعه الاساس فيها انها
اصبحت ميناء كبير واقعه على مديك ملقى
وديق ملقى ده احد اهم ان لم يكن اهم معبر
مائي في العالم رقم واحد في العالم رقم
واح واحد في العالم وبالتالي ف دوله
سنغافوره قامت على اساس انها ميناء في
البدايه تمام بعد استقلالها عن بريطانيا
سنه 63 ثم استقلالها عن الاتحاد الفيدرالي
مع ماليزيا سنه 65 كل الانشطه اللاحقه
ارتبطت بال الثوره او بالبوم او بالطف
التي حدثت في ميناء تمام سنغافوره ثم من
انشطه الميناء الاساسيه الى انشطه اخرى
كثيره منطقه تجاره حره مناطق صناعيه
التمويل كل شيكل شيء لكن نقطه البدايه
كانت الميناء عندي بس ملحوظه صغيره حضرتك
قلت انه الجي دي بي بتاع سنغافوره 466
مليار دولار هذا سليم بس لما بنقول الناتج
المحلي بالنسبه لمصر طبعا اتمنى يكون اكتر
من كده كتير مع فرق السكان 477 ولكن هو
الفكره ده على اي سعر صرف لو حسبناه على
سعر الصرف بقى 31 بفيض هيبقى اقل من النص
مسوب على 31 انما لو حصل تخفيض هينزل جامد
يعني اه طبعا هيبقى تقريبا نص الجي دي بي
لجزيره صغيره سنغافوره وعشان تتخيلوا حجم
سنغافوره اللي هي حوالي 734 يعني قد
تقريبا ضعف مساحه غزه شريط غزه الصغير
يعني جزيره صغيره جدا انا اسف للمقاطعه
حضرتك احنا وقفنا عند
انه قناه السويس انسحبت اه جه في سنه 90
كان في مؤتمر نقل بحري عالمي في
اسكندريه فانا قدمت ورقه
بحثيه رؤيه مستقبليه لقناه
السويس قلت قناه السويس بتهتم بمحور واحد
فقط اللي هي الملاحه والعبور
وفقط قناه السويس لازم تبقى في محورين
ثانيين اهم جدا من رسوم العبور قناه
السويس ما بتديش فيهم حاجه خالص هم ايه
محور
الخدمات للسفن اللي بتعبر لقناه السويس
وكذلك حجم البضايع اللي بتعبر في قناه
السويس ما بتشارك فيها مالهاش اي دور
ماتعملش قيمه مضافه على البضائع نهائ فانا
اقترحت
ان مصر تخش مجال الخدمات في النقل البحري
والسفن زي تزويد السفن
بالوقود تخش في مجال اصلاح السفن تخش في
مجال بنى السفن توريدات للسفن ا تخش في
مجالات
العطر واعمال تكريك وحاجات كتيره جدا في
الخدمات البحريه زي ما سنغافوره بتقدم اي
بلد وقع على خطوط الملاحه العالميه بتقدم
هذه الخدمات تغيير العطا تسجيل السفن
ا يبقى لها اسطول بحري واخد بال سيادتك
وكذلك مشاركه في الخدمات عن طريق يبقى في
مراكز توزيع مراكز تصنيع مراكز قيمه مضافه
مراكز لوجستيه وكذا فالحقيقه يعني الدوله
اهتمت بهذا
البحث
وتم طلب ملخص له لعرضه على رئيس مريه في
ذلك الوقت الرئيس حسني
مبارك فالرئيس حسني مبارك جاب رئيس
الوزراء كان الله يرحمه الدكتور الجنزوري
وقال له احنا عاوزين نطبق هذا
الكلام فالدكتور
الجنزوري
جاب ثلاث رجال
اعمال
وشك ل ثلات
شركات مثلا شركه تنميه خليج السويس دي كان
احمد
عز الشركه الثانيه كان شركه الرادو دي كان
لراجل
الاعمال اللي هو ابو العنين محمد ابو
العنين الشركه الثالثه لساويرس شركه
السويس للتنميه والشركه الرا شركه انشات
بين الصين ومصر
لتنميه
المنطقه ادى لكل رجل اعمال تقريبا 20 كيل
متر
مربع بتاع الحديد عمل له مصنع حديد بتاع
السيراميك عمل له مصنع
سيراميك الثاني اسم وعمل مصنع خرصانه
جاهزه ومصنع ورق وكلام ايه ومصنع اسمتها
ا الشركه الصينيه خططت ودخلت مرافق في
تقريبا 1د ونص كيلو وعملت شركه
للرخام كانت بتنقل تقريبا كل يوم 15
كونتينر رخام من جبل الجلاله بتنقله على
الصين بعد ثمان
سنين من هذا من هذا المقترح اللي هو 97 من
ا ما فيش
تقدم حاجه عشوائيه واخد بالك ما فيش ربط
ما فيش تخيل ايه الانشطه المفروض
موطنها ازاي تتكامل هذه الانشطه
وكذا فلقوا نسبه التنميه
3.3% من المساحه اللي خدوها وكلها حاجات
لا ترقى لهذا الموقع والمامول
منه في
سنه
2000 و 2 صدر قانون المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخاصه لشمال غرب خليج
السويس القانون ده ادى حوافز
للمستثمرين بقت نسبه الضرايب على النشاط
اللي فيها 10% والضريبه على الدخل 5% وادك
اعفاءات على مكونات الانتاج اللي بتجيبها
وكذلك على صادرات من
المنتجات انما مافيش تقطم
فجاب
شركه متخصصه في المناطق الصناعيه
واللوجستيه والكلام ده من ايرلندا اي دي
اي تقيم التجربه بعد هذه الفتره من في
2005 مثلا جت الشركه تقريبا 2005 لان حضك
قلت بعد ممان سنوات ما فيش تقدم فاكيد
جابوها بقى في
2005 في
الشركه قالت يا جماعه اللي بتعملوه ده
مالوش علاقه بالمناطق الاقتصاديه العالميه
اللي بتخدم التجاره العالميه
و البنيه اللي انتم عملتوها دي بنيه ضعيفه
جدا ولا تصلى
وفي تنافس من اصحاب الارض ومضاربات
والعمليه كده المرافق اللي انتم عاملينها
مش على
المستوى هذا الموضوع كله لا يرقى ان
الايميل من هذه المنطقه واقترحت الشركه ان
احنا نبتدي ب 5 كيلو متر
يتم
ترفقها على المستوى العالمي
وخطط ماستر بلان لها وايه الصناعات
والانشطه اللي احنا عاوزين هكذا واقترحت
ان ده هيكون هيكلف تقريبا
500 مليون دولار ف مصر شكلت شركه قبضه
لمنطقه شمال غرب خليج السويس
ودخلت المستثمرين دول طبقا للي عاوز يخش
يخش
وكلف
الدكتور وزير الاسكان في ذلك الوقت ان يحل
المشاكل بتاعه
المنطقه واعطي الاشراف للمنطقه لوزير
الاستثمار كان الدكتور محمود محي
الدين فدكتور محمود محي الدين قال لك
والله اللي عاوز يشتغل طبقا للقانون 159
يشتغل اللي عاوز يشتغل لقانون المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخاصه يشتغل اللي عايز يشتغل
كذا اذا مادش في قانون موحد للمنطقه
وماعدش فيه رؤيه شامله في العمليه ايه برض
ما تقدمت خالص نتيجه عدم مضوع
الرؤيه وعدم وجود
متخصصين في هذه الانشطه والتنميه مثل هذه
المحاور العالميه بس هم كانوا استقروا على
فين مكان ال 5 كيلو متر مربع اللي هيبدا
بيهم بالضبط كده وسحبوا من الاراضي من
اللي كانت مخصصه دي للاربع شركات السابقه
الشركات فيما عاد الاجزاء اللي هم عملوا
فيها مصانع سبوها لهم صانع موجوده حتى
الان ا ومازال
بعد كده قامت الثوره في
2011 فانا الحقيقه تقدمت لرئيس الوزراء
الدكتور عصام شرف
ب
دراسه يعني محدثه لهذا المشروع وايه اللي
حصل فيه وايه اللي ممكن نحصل من هذا
المشروع اذا اتحط على الطريق الصح وادير
صح
الدكتور
عصام نتيجه مشغوليات كرئيس وزراء حولني ل
المستشاره الاقتصاديه له كانت الدكتوره
نجلاء الاهواني في هذا الوقت اللي مسك بعد
كده وزيره التعاون الدولي وزاره التعاون
الدولي بالضبط قت اشرح لها هذا
الكلام وما تمش
حاجه بعد ما الدكتور عصام طلع من رئاسه قي
شهرين او شهور يعني فتره صغيره بيتصل
بي واصلا استاذ نقل بحري اصبر هو استاذ
نقل اه واحد بال سدك طرق نقل قال لي عندك
مانع تتعاون معانا في تنفيذ المقترح اللي
انت بعد ما خرج من الحكومه طلع خرج من
الحكومه فقلت له انت اذا كنت وانت في
الحكومه ما قدرتش تعمل حاجه فلما تخرج قال
لي لا احنا هنكون مجموعه عمل
و نشتغل في هذا الموضوع فتكونت مجموعه عمل
من مجموعه من
التكنوقراط ناس افاضل دكتور محمد علي
دكتور خالد
حنفي اللوا الله يرحمه شيرين حسن
انا المهندس علي بسيوني الله يرحمه
المستشار طاهر حزين و رجعنا كل مخططات هذا
المحور من اول اليابانيين بالتطورات اللي
كذا وحطينا خطه بديله الا ان حصل خلافات
بين الحكومه في هذا الوقت كانت حكومه
ممثله
لاخوان والمجموعه دي
استقالت الخلاف كان على ايه ياخدوا يعني
ايه كان الخلاف الاساسي هي كانت حكومه مين
الاول اللي هو هو المهندس اظن انديل
المهندس هشام انديل هشام انديل هو كان
مهندس ري بالمناسبه اه الاختلاف في وجهتنا
ده كانت ايام حكومه الدكتور محمد مرسي بقى
بالظبط كده اه طيب
تمام المجموعه بتاعتنا كلنا استنا لقيناهم
بيشدوه في اتجاه حاجه ثانيه يعني باجا
شديد ايه يعني يعني بيفصل سينا عن المحور
احنا كنا
واخدين المنطقه ككل واخد بالك
لتنميتها اللي هي بورسعيد اسماعيليه
السويس سينا الشماليه سينا الجنوبيه قلنا
ده المنطقه دي كلها ممكن تنميتها وتبقى هي
قاطره الاقتصاد المصري انتم كمجموعه قدمتم
مشروع حكومه الدكتور هشام انديل في ظل حكم
الرئيس السابق الدكتور محمد مرسي الخلاف
الرئيس او ما دفعكم للاستقاله بايجاز شديد
كان ايه يعني لما جوم يعملوا قانون لهذه
المنطقه كانوا عاوزين يفصلو كلها عن مصر
وكذا فحس ان انت في حاجه مش مظبوطه لا
تقبلها يعني هذه المنطقه جزء من مصر
وهتفضل طول عمرها جزء من مصر ف تبقى تحت
اداره مثلا مستثمرين اجانب
مثلا الهيئه اللي يعينوه بقى لادارتها
واخذ بالك اه اه ده السبب يعني وفي اسباب
اخرى يعني مش مافيش داعي لذكره طيب
تمام بس هم في البدايه رحبوا بمشروع حضرتك
واخدوه او بمشروع المجموعه بالب ثم اختلفت
على التفاصيل او هو كان لهم تصور اخر طيب
انا حضك متحفظ على التصور بس عشان اقول
للمشاهدين وحرك عاوز اتكلم عنه بالتفصيل
في وقت لاحق يعني
افضل ج في سنه
2015 الرئيس السيسي
اصدر قانون معدل لمحور قناه السويس وشكل
مجلس اداره وعين رئيس
للمحور قناه السويس
وتبادل بقى الرئاسه عليه كذا
واحد للاسف يعني ما كانش
عندهم خبره ولا رؤيه لمثل هذه المشاريع
الضخمه اللي بتخدم الاقتصاد العالم وازاي
يربط الاقتصاد المصري مع الاقتصاد العالمي
ولغايه هذه اللحظه اللي احنا فيها
بنتعرض ما انت سعدتك شايف تحرك لك وصف انه
هذا المشروع طبعا هو اهميته الدوليه لا
تخفى على احد كل دول العالم هتستفيد منه
زي ما كل دول العالم بتستفيد من سنغافوره
وجبل علي وكل المشاريع الضخمه اللي هي
بتقوم على خدمه التجاره البحريه لكن حضرتك
دايما بتوصفه لما بكلم حضرتك مند سنوات
تقول لي هذا كنز مصر المفقود تمام ليه
بتصفه بانه محور قناه السويس هذا الكنز
مصر المفقود انت في
ايدك ترتبط بالاقتصاد العالمي وتبقى حلقه
اساسيه من حلقات الامداد القوني للاقتصاد
العالمي ومراكز لوجستيه وصناعيه وخدميه كل
ده في ايدك بس هات اللي خطط صح وهات الناس
من العالم كله اللي عندهم خبره في اداره
مثل
هذه المحاور يعني دي سيادتك مثال
اخر في
محور اسمه ديله بب في الهند ده طوله
تقريبا
1504 كيلو ده
بيمر في ست ولايات في
الهند جابوا مين يخططه جابوا اليابان
الجيك خططت هذا المحور وحطوا اهداف
محدده قال لك هذا المحور هيرفع الناتج
الصناعي لثلاث اضعاف في خلال خمس سنين
هيخلق فرص عمل مضاعفه خلال خمس سنين هيزود
الصادرات
الهند اربع اضعاف خلال خمس سنين وعمل فيه
مركز صناعيه ولوجستيك
ومناطق صناعيه حره وهكذا وبجانب طبعا شبكه
طرق وسكك حديد على المستوى العالمي
اليابان مش بس خططت وبس ده كذلك سهمت في
التمويل مستفيد هي تستفيد وساهمت
26% من نفقات تنميه هذا المحور وشكلوا
مجلس اداره من ناس على مستوى عالي جدا
واستفادوا من الخبرات العالميه فمن هنا
يعني من يومين اثنين كان رئيس وزراء الهند
بيفتت احد المراحل اللي فيه دول ابتدوا
كام سنه
2015 يعني هم اليابان ابتدت في فكره 2013
خلصوا التخطيط والكلام ده 2015 ابتدوا
التنفيذ شوف احنا من ايه بان
تقريبا من سنه 4 سنه محلك سر
انا عاوز انا الحقيقه قبل ما اسال حضرتك
عن المشروعات المماثله يعني احنا قناه
السويس في الوقت الحالي هي عباره عن معبر
يعني السفينه تمر منها من البحر الاحمر
للبحر المتوسط او من البحر المتوصل الى
البحر الاحمر وهيئه قناه السويس بتحصل على
فيز او مقابل على ذلك تمام فده يدر على
مصر حوالي ست س مليار دولار في السنه في
المتوسط يعني مش كده برض بالظبط كده بس
السن
وصلنا ل 10 وثلا وهنوصل في ديسمبر نهايه
هذا الشهر 10 و3 من دي نسبه بسييطه جدا
مما يجب ان تجيبها لا تتجاوز
5% من المفروض تجيبوا هذا المحور لو اشتغ
5% يعني بتتكلم على 200 واكتر من 200 200
مليار دولار مليار دولار لو انت اشتغلت
بقى في الخدمات الصح ومراكز صناعيه ومرا
مراكز توزيع ومراكز لوجستيه وكل دوت يخليك
من حاله لحاله احنا لسه كنا بنتكلم على
سنغابور من جزيره صغيره جدا فقيره وصلت
لايه ودخل الفرد فيها ايه فانت عندك نفس
الامكانيات فما تستغلها انا عندي سؤال
لحضرتك يا باشمهندس هو في حال انه المشروع
طبعا المشروع ماشي بوتيره بطيئه زي ما
حضرتك بتقول ماشي بوتيره بطيئه حضرتك
السبب الرئيسي اللي قلت قلت اشرت اليه
اللي هو عدم
وجود رؤيه واضحه وسلطه للمنطقه على كامل
هذه المنطقه المستثمر مالوش اي علاقه غير
بهذه المنطقه تخلص له كل حاجه وفي مرونه
مناخ استثمار جاذب زي المناخ العالمي
يعتبرها هذه المنطقه جزء من العالم عشان
تشتغل مع العالم كله
وليست بقى خلصها من البيروقراطيه
والقوانين المقيده و و و يبقى عندك ا نوع
من التشريعات
الاقتصاديه ونوع من فض النزاعات السريع
جدا في شفافيه بنيه اساسيه على المستوى
العالمي واخد بالك كل اللي وفرت كل هذا
الكلام هم هيجوا لك الشركات المتعدده
الجنسيه دي ويعملوا هذا الكلام زي عمله في
سنغافوره
مثلا
هو في حال انه مصر اشتغلت على هذا المشروع
برؤيه سليمه وجابت ناس اكثر فهما من كل
دول العالم
وخلصت المنطقه من البيروقراطيه وعملت كل
ده ايه هي المشروعات اللي ممكن هذا
المشروع
ينافسها وبالتالي يضيق عليها او ينافسها
بمعنى اصح
يعني يعني انت بلا شك هتخش تنافس شديد جدا
مع جبل علي وسنغافوره يعني مثلا سنغافوره
ا رقم واحد في تموينات السفن في العالم
بكل انواع الوقود سواء بنكين سواء وقود
غاز مثال
سواء هيدروجين اخضر في المستقبل انت عندك
هذه الامكانيه في المنطقه محور قناه
السويس تبقى تبقى مركز رئيسي لتم
السفن مركز رئيسي لاصلاح السفن مركز رئيسي
لبونى السفن انت عندك مثلا
سنغفوره
70%
من البلاتفورم بتاع اكتشاف البترول والغاز
في العالم بيصنع في في سنغافور فانت لازم
تبقى كده يعني ده انت مثلا ما عندكش مصنع
بيعمل حاويات فما بالك لو عملت مصنع
للحاويات الصين مسيط طر على 92% من سوق
الحيوي واخد بالك ممكن يبقى يجيلك دخل من
هذا الكلام فوق ال 4 مليار دولار واخد بال
منافسيك الرئيسيين هيكونوا سنغافوره وجبل
علي وجبل علي واخد بال سيادتك لان دول
يعني سنغافوره لانها وقع على ممر التجاره
العالميه 20% رقم واحد انت بيمر عندك 12%
ما بتستفيد منهم في حاجه غير بتاخد رسومه
بس فدي المشكله فلازم قانس يشتغل على
محورين
خدمات ومشاركه في التجاره عا اسال حضرك
سؤال يا باشمهندس حضرتك قلت لنا كلام كتير
عن محور قناه السويس ايه اهم شيء يعني
الصوره العامه ان حضرتك بتقول ما تم
انجازه حتى الان لا يرقى الى ما نتمنى ايه
اهم شيء تم انجازه حتى الان في محور قناه
السويس انا
اعتقد المواني الجديده اللي انشات سواء في
السخنه او في شرق بورسعيد
والمناطق الصناعيه الملحقه بها والمناطق
الحار دي بقى لو تم جذب استثمارات فيها
وادير صح يعتبر ان جاز جايد جدا وكذلك
وادي التكنولوجيا عاوز دفعه كبيره جدا لان
انت عندك ريميل ممكن
تعمل السيليكون وتنقيها وتخش في صناعه بقى
السولار سيل وتبقى والشيبس الرقائق
والشيبس وده بوتينشن كبير جدا واخد بالك
بس عاوز مجهود منك عشان تمشي في هذا
الاتجاه وتتخصص فيه هل هل مصادر التمويل
ممكن تكون عائق ولا دول كتيره مهتمه ان هي
تستثمر هو اذا توفرت الظروف الجيده يعني
دول كتيره مهتمه جدا انها تستثمر عندك بس
عاوز نوع من الاستقرار
السياسي
والتشريعي وتبسيط الاجراءات والمناخ يبقى
زي اي مناخ في العالم لماذا هيجيلك هذا
راس المال ويستثمر عندك زي ما حصل في دوله
سنغافوره اللي اتكلمنا عليها لماذا
اليابان تحديدا كانت اكثر اهتماما بمحور
قناه السويس من
غيرها
اليابان يعني من الدول الجيده جدا اللي
ساعدتنا سواء في قناه السويس لما جينا
نفتحها في سنه 75
و اه عندنا مخطط كامل لتطوير قناه السويس
على مراحل الى ان تصل
لازدواج بس كل مرحله قبل ما ننفذها بنشوف
ايه المتغيرات ونعمل دراسه جدوى نلاقي لها
جدوى نشتغل فيها فاليابان
لها علاقه جيده بمصر ومهتمه جدا بقناه
السويس وعندها من الداتا والمعلومات عن
قناه السويس مش متوفر عند حد
تاني لان هي ساعدتنا في فتح القناه في وضع
الراسات رسوم العجور شكلها ايه التجاره
العالميه شكلها ايه وعلمت ناس كتير في
الهيئه ايه يعني ايه التجاره عالميه وازاي
اقتصادياتها والكلام من ده والباشمهندس
بيشير الى عمليه افتتاح قناه السويس بعد
انتهاء الحرب لانها كانت تم وقف الملاحه
فيها من 67 يا باشمهندس من 67 لغايه 75
لغايه 75 وطبعا نتيجه اعم العدائيات
والحروب كانت في اماكن كامله مغلقه
بالكامل يعني الغام والغام الى اخره
وبالمناسبه دي تجربه حضرتك شاركت فيها ان
شاء الله في حلقه ثانيه
ممكن نتحدث عنها لما سالت حضرتك عن اهم ما
تم انجازه في محور قناه السويس اشرت الى
ما اشرت اليه هل عمليه ازدواج القناه مش
برض ده واحد من الامور
الايجابيه بلا شك هي مرحله من المراحل لان
احنا لو شوفنا كده التجاره في سنه مثلا
2050 20
50 هتجد التجاره اللي بتعبر قناه السويس
هتوصل
3500 مليون طن ما تستوعبها سويس لازم تبقى
مزدوجه بالكامل قناه رايحه وقناه جايه
فانت
عندك الاطوال المزدوجه النهارده في قناه
السويس
123 كيلو
و03 القناه كلها 190 و03 فقدامك 60 كيلو
بس 60 كيلو دول في اصعب جزء اللي هو ناحيه
السويس الارض صلبه جدا فهتا اخد منك مجهود
وتكلفه جامده انا جزيل الشكر باشمهندس
يعني حضرك اديتنا
اطلاله شامله ويعني صحيح انه الصوره ليست
مبهجه لكن نتمنى في السنوات المقبله يكون
الوضح ايدك كنز استغل هذا الكنز عشان تطلع
من الازمه الاقتصاديه بتاعتك جزيل الشكر
باش مهندس شكرا شكرا لحضراتكم وان شاء
الله نلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن الله